-Our first guest tonight is an
Academy Award-nominated actres
you know from films such a
"Little Women" and "Midsommar.
She's currently starring i
Marvel's "Black Widow,"
which is in theaters now
and on Disney+ with
premier access.
Let's take a look.
-Where are trying to get?
-Motorbike!
East side of the building!
[ Gasps ]
♪♪♪♪
-Please welcome to the sho
Florence Pugh!
How are you, Florence?
-Hi. I'm good. How you doing
-Good. Excellent roof work
in that clip.
-Thank you.
Did you like that kick?
-Everything about it.
I feel like
to be an action star
in today's cinema,
you have to be able to
do it on a roof,
and you just --
it was impeccable.
Every part of it
was impeccable.
-Yeah, you have to be able t
slide down a burning hot roo
in Budapest.
-You know what?
Nobody every thinks about
how hot those roofs must be.
-Yeah. Put that
straight on your CV.
-There you go. Yes.
You're like, a certain heat,
I know a lot of actors
would just beg right out.
You're willing to do it.
-Well, when I'm doing it
with Scarlett,
it's more fun than it is pain,
so, I mean, I did have
a good action partner.
-That's very true.
That's very true.
And it's a joy
to see you in the film.
It must be a joy for you, afte
a year of no travel at all
be able to get out and promote
this film to some degree.
-Yeah. Totally.
For everyone
it's been a long year,
but I spent the most of it awa
from my family and my friends,
and so when I was
finished filming in L.A.,
I finally got back to see them
and hug them all,
so it's been a really nice
few months doing press here.
-And you got to
be with your family.
This was at the premiere?
-[ Gasps ] Yeah!
-What a lovely bunch
you guys are.
-You can see where
I got my height from.
-Yeah.
Yeah, that's very true.
I guess if somebody said,
based on this,
which one's the action star,
you maybe would maybe
underestimate you.
Well done.
-I'm wondering, I've heard tel
that your family is
very supportive.
They love to come out
and see you in films.
I feel like you've been
in the kind of films
that families
would love to watch.
For example, "Midsommar,"
which one of my favorite
movies of recent years.
That might not be
as family-friendly.
-Well, you know
what was funny is,
I, because I was
filming at the time,
I couldn't do press and go t
the premiere for "Midsommar,
so I took my family
to a local view in Oxford,
and I was like,
"Ooh, everybody,
let's go and watch
the first screening."
And I took my granddad and m
gran and my mum and my sister,
and we all sat down,
and at the end, my granddad,
who does not watch movies
like "Midsommar,"
came up to me and
he put his hand on my shoulder
and he said, "Well,
if you weren't in it,
I wouldn't watch it."
And I was like, "Oh.
Okay.
Great."
-I mean, I'll be honest.
I think that's very true
of a lot of grandparents.
And I should note that
for people who haven't
seen "Midsommar,"
it sounds like
a British period drama
that grandparents would love
and it is decidedly not.
-No, I think you find out
very, very quickly
that it's not gonna have
anything to do with
quaint summer teatimes
or any high tea summer,
which is...
-I'm wondering, too, you know,
one of the fun things
about the Marvel Universe
is how things
in previous films are laid i
and then they pay off later.
If you have a family
that's maybe less invested
in the Cinematic Universe,
how is it when their first
sort of entree
is seeing their daughter
in "Black Widow?"
-Well, it's very tricky
to explain --
well, I mean, unless you'v
watched these movies
and you're invested in them,
you don't know
that there are
different universes
and that there are
different superheroes
connected
to different universes,
so my gran, for the last year,
keeps on saying "Superwoman,
and I'm like, "I wish, but no.
I'm Yelena,
an equally cool badass."
And then when I sat next to my
mum at the premiere in England
I had to keep on --
and she wasn't asking,
but I kept on leaning over
and being like,
"So, she's a real, real baddie
and he's really nasty,
and he's done all these ba
things to all these women.
And then something else
would happen, I'd be like,
"So the reason why that's funn
is because four movies ago --"
And I had to kind of
pinch myself for a moment,
being like, "Oh, I'm that person
that's now talking throughou
the entire screening,
and it's my movie,
and I'm explaining
the plot to my mum."
So, you know. It's fun.
It's part of it.
-I feel like you should
get a waiver
that allows you
to talk through a film
if it's your film
and you're politely trying t
keep your mother up to speed
-And I was the person
that was like,
"Everybody sit down.
There's a post-credit scene!
It was me that did that.
So, yeah. Apologies, everyone.
-A few years back,
you were in
a wonderful adaptation
of the John le Carre book
"Little Drummer Girl."
You were wonderful in it.
I'm very jealous,
you got to meet the man himself.
Le Carre being his pen name.
You met David Cornwell.
What was he like?
-Yeah, I met him, and I was,
I am good friend with him.
I actually met him
at the end of the shoot,
which was quite daunting,
because I know that
Charlie, the character,
was based on his sister,
so I'm aware that there's
a lot of pressure
with playing someone
that is so close to him.
And I met him at
the end of the shoot,
so I was like, "Oh, my God
What if he hates
what I've been doing?"
And I sat next to him
at this dinner.
There was a lot of,
you know, anxiety
to meeting
the great David Cornwell.
And I remember we sat down
and we had a few argy-barg
comments to each other,
and he said something
that I was just like,
not okay with.
And so I called him an old fart,
and he looked at me
and he said,
"What did you just call me?"
And I said,
"You're being an old fart.
And I remember he, like,
twinkled at me,
and it was from that moment on
and he said,
"I think we're gonna get along."
And we were best friends
ever since.
I really, really,
I have a lot of love for him
and this year, it was painfu
saying goodbye to him,
but everybody knows
he's an amazing man.
He's written
some fantastic greats.
-He really has.
And so many of them have bee
wonderful film and televisio
adaptations,
as with yours.
Hey, thank you so much
for making the time for us
-Thank you!
-I know you have to do so much
press for a film this big,
and I hope you can relax
a little bit now.
-Thank you so much.
All my love to you guys
over there. Thank you.
-"Black Widow" is in theater
everywhere now.